well we begin in Sudan we're fighting
between the Army and the rapid support
forces is Raging for a tenth day
thousands of people are fleeing the
violence and more than 400 have been
killed many neighborhoods have also been
left without access to food or clean
water and the country is experiencing a
near total internet blackout rahila
Muhammad begins our coverage
people in Khartoum are living in the
middle of a war zone
what was once a bustling Market is now
piles of rubble buildings and homes are
in Ruins
near my house here
we are suffering of lack of food lack of
ethnicity lack of water we do not have
electricity for three days now and also
we do not have
access to water
people say relatives are missing but
they can't go out and search for them as
they're too scared to leave the house
doctors have described the situation as
catastrophic
the hospital is still operational but
not to the full capacity due to the
shortage of medical equipment let alone
difficulty the medical staff face to get
to work
the fighting in the capital is centered
around the presidential Palace and the
Army Headquarters this video appears to
Show members of the paramilitary rapid
support forces with their Commander
General Muhammad hamdan daglow in the
area but it's not clear when it was
filmed
across the Nile River in the city of
omdurman some people are bearing their
dead this home was hit by shelling while
the family was asleep
I have burns on my body and I couldn't
stand up but God helped me many shells
came into my room and I collected them
they hid the room and came through the
window they broke the glass I was lying
in bed and when I stood up I fell to the
ground
[Applause]
in darduk north of Khartoum there are
pockets of resistance some people took
to the streets in protest on Saturday
calling for an end to the violence
analysts say Sudan's longer waited
transition to civilian rule a prospect
that seemed imminent a few weeks ago is
moving further Out Of Reach
for as long as general Douglas and army
Chief Abdul fatah al-burhan refused to
back down
one of them needs to win so that he
could claim power this is how they see
it from both ends uh and and ultimately
they have no problem in my opinion
sacrificing whatever it it takes like a
compromising or jeopardizing the
security of the whole uh country
and all the while Sudanese live in fear
as more of their country is destroyed in
a battle for power rahila Muhammad
al-jazeera
well after a week of battles the delayed
rescues many countries are scrambling to
evacuate their citizens and diplomats
for Jordanian claims landed at a man
military airport as you see there
carrying more than 300 people from Port
Sudan Spain Germany and France also
pulled out hundreds of their citizens on
Sunday and more countries have announced
evacuation plans in the coming days our
correspondent hibber Morgan has more
from cartoon
well there are two kinds of evacuations
Happening Here in the capital Khartoum
this is the evacuation of foreign
Nationals with the help from their
embassies and Allied countries uh here
in the in the capital many of them
making their way to the eastern city of
Port Sudan just like the U.N Mission
here in the country uh and Port Sudan is
a city that's about 800 kilometers away
from the capital so that's a trip on a
normal day that would take about 11 to
12 hours but because there would be
checkpoints on the road and because it's
a large Convoy it's likely to take
longer than that and those are the
foreign Nationals evacuating then
there's the locals the residents of
Hartung themselves who are doing their
own evacuations mapping out their own
routes outside the capital to make it to
Safe places places like Jazeera in the
central part of the country or River
Nile in the northern part of the country
there are also some Sudanese who are
trying to evacuate the country
completely not just to neighboring
states they're trying to move to
neighboring countries like Egypt
Ethiopia Orchard and South Sudan they're
simply looking for ways depending on
where they are depending on the fighting
at the time that they're trying to move
to make it out of the capital whether
that be to a neighboring state or
neighboring country in the end let's not
forget that this is the first time
harsum is actually actually witnessing a
displacement Khartoum is not a city that
has witnessed conflict despite the fact
that Sudan has had numerous words going
on within its borders but never in
Khartoum so people are very unused to
the situation
escaped Sudan for Egypt on Saturday and
she described what it was like fleeing
the violence there with her family
getting out of Sudan was not an easy
decision to make it was not an easy
Journey
um what I would recommend to my sisters
and brothers that are trying to please
Sudan right now is
um you need to be brave uh please take
care of each other uh don't carry too
much money or too many clothes packed
lightly make sure you have plenty of
food and plenty of drinking water the
journey is really really long and when
you think about it just go for it
um don't think of the what ifs just
please try to get out and be safe uh
getting out of fortomo is definitely the
most difficult part of this entire
Journey
um having to go through these uh
checkpoints where you don't know whether
you're going to be robbed or killed or
um just uh holding my mother's hands
looking into my grandma's eyes just all
holding each other's hands and praying
that it all goes smoothly
um I would say that even though it was
the shortest part of the trip it was
definitely the most nerve-wracking the
situation has just gotten so much worse
than the last few days
um people have completely run out of
food clean drinking water the hospitals
are almost at
um zero capacity they're completely not
working
um there's no petrol people can't move
around even evacuations these if like
when we evacuated it was way much easier
uh it was smooth uh the even at the
border there weren't that many people
but now these borders are filled with so
many people and it is turning into a
full-blown humanitarian crisis
um that needs to be stopped as ceasefire
needs to be put into place and the
people of Sudan need to be evacuated
safely
you just had none talking about a
humanitarian crisis in Sudan well the
fighting is already is exacerbating and
already difficult humanitarian situation
there the UN humanitarian office says
about 15.8 million people roughly a
third of the population will need
assistance this year there are 3.7
million internally displaced people too
who need help around 4 million children
under five and pregnant women are
acutely malnourished and need
life-saving services and as many as 11.7
million people simply don't have enough
food to eat
well Kate minor volley is cares East and
Central Africa Regional director she
says the violence is worsening the
crisis
one of the things that we are always
conscious about as care is that women
and girls and children are always the
most disproportionately affected by
violence and so some of the realities
with these Journeys as they flee is the
risk to sexual and gender-based violence
for women and girls
um and so recognizing that reality we
are deeply concerned about what this
ongoing conflict means for women and
girls and how it impacts them
we also know that Sudan in itself from
an economic from an economic point of
view when you think about what is the
implication of this war on on
on the social what is the social impact
of this crisis this current violence
deepens an already existing Humanity
humanitarian crisis in a country that
was already struggling economically with
Rising food prices devastating floods
disease outbreaks and our experience has
shown that those who are already highly
vulnerable had very few coping
mechanisms and so right now with this
conflict with a few coping mechanisms
that they had they are left with none
this is the reality for those who are
staying in cartoon for those who face
the conflicts in their environment and
for those who are now tracking to to the
Border